on the podcast we did a prank call the
other day and somebody was
getting really mad really mad and rich
like my nick goes reveal reveal reveal
tell him it's a joke tell him it's you
so i phoned back and i go hey buddy he
goes yeah can i help you i phoned him
back like the 10th time he goes i go
it's howie mandel it's howie mandel
and this is a joke he goes okay howie
mandel can i help you i go no i'm just
telling you that that was a as a prank
he goes so you don't need any you know
plumbing equipment or anything i go
no i'm just because then go [ __ ]
yourself that was my reveal it wasn't
good for the ego but it was such a fail
for
me and my podcast
but i did one the other day i know you
talked to we did one with bobby lee oh
yeah this is also a bad one
rich was mad at me for this where we
called a guy i know a guy that was
dating a girl finished dating the girl
and the girl was
pregnant and he did not know whether
the baby was his or the next guy she was
dating and we found out it was the next
guy she was dating but i knew that he
didn't know yet
so we had bobby lee
call as a doctor from a a clinic yeah a
very shady clinic i'm sure
and with her father i played her father
telling him that
the baby
the dna test came back the baby is his
and uh i as the father of the the mother
i'm gonna talk to him about his
intentions and put together some uh
wedding arrangements and
he just he just started crying
oh
and i hung up before the reveal that's
why you were mad at me i never
so you guys just ruined somebody's day
really yeah i was terrified like crazy
and then he gets the peak of everything
and how he goes i'm sorry he hangs up i
go call him back let him know he goes no
we're not calling him back
no because the last time i called back
on that other prank
it was the plumber guy who goes i don't
give a [ __ ] here howie mandel i'm not
going through that again we've just been
talking about
health and our ego i'm not going to lay
it on my ego again it's not worth it i
think you let god and that man figure it
out
you know i really think you do man
that was the right choice i know
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one